hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from the super
United rabbit and Blitz tournament
currently being played in zagative
Croatia it is gookish versus Magnus
Carlsen and I apologize for magnus's
rating I accidentally left the the
rating from the previous video that I've
made uh speaking of which if you haven't
seen my previous video do check it out
it's one of the best uh games that you
will see let me just switch this it's
actually
28.35 actually left the first digit
because well very rarely someone rated 1
000 and something in the videos that I
make but okay here I've fixed it but
yeah do check out the previous video
that I've made where Ivana muches with
the black pieces defeats all of the
players of the grand Chester of uh the
supernatural rapper than Blitz Croatia
but now we turn to India it will be the
first link in the description below and
now we uh tickets to Google versus
Magnus Carlsen uh I mean it it it truly
doesn't get any better than this the
Magnus is of course always looking for
new ways on how to deliver quick defeats
to these up and coming players and Lucas
isn't really even an up-and-coming
player anymore he is an established
player he took down pretty much everyone
he even defeated Magnus carlsening over
the board chess uh if you remember I've
shown the game he defeated him in Norway
chess and and not not so long ago he
actually did on his birthday so of
course Magnus will be looking for ways
to retaliate and for those of you who
haven't seen the previous video here the
participants are Yani polish affiruja
Fabiano caruana
Rapport Magnus Carlsen Evans
Constantinople and of course
vishwanathan Anand and the tournament is
actually a third stage of the 2023 Grand
Chester a series of five events with a
total prize fund of 1.4 million dollars
so you know the the time control is uh
rapid they will have 25 minutes for the
entire game plus 10 seconds increment
starting from move one so there you have
it that's a little bit of an info that I
always present when I'm showing the
first game of the tournament but I will
not be repeating that showing the other
games of the tournament so let's check
it out uh versus Magnus Carlsen and
gookish opens with Ponte E4 and of
course we all know what Magnus replies
to E4 Pawn to C5 Magnus goes for the
Sicilian Defense Knight to F3 we have
Knight the C6 and Bishop to B5 going for
the uh Nish Medina rosalimo attack
against the Sicilian and usually uh I
mean in faster time formats players will
challenge Magnus to a C3 Sicilian or a
bishop to B5 Sicilian very rarely will
someone challenge Magnus to an open
Sicilian uh so you know uh very
interesting we have G6 uh castles and
now Bishop to G7 Pawn to C3 and Knight
to F6 we have Rook D1 and the Magnus
Castle's King side we have Pawn to D4
and now Pawn to D5 uh is the move that
Google Play C cappers on D4 is a bit
more popular but okay anything can be
played here with D5 E5 and Knight the E4
we have Bishop D3 all non moves nothing
new here captures captures and D for end
Queen to B6 putting pressure on the
bishop here uh straighten C6 Bishop for
Knight Bishop captures and C6 Queen
captures you could capture with the B
Pawn uh Magnus but first uh to capture
with the queen and now Knight B to D2
and here there are some games where
Bishop to G4 was played also F5 is a
known move uh but here uh instead of uh
Bishop to G4 or point five we have
Bishop to F5 and it is now as of move 12
that we have a completely new game so
okay Knight to B3 uh end up on the B6
Magnus nicely controlling the Knight on
B3 not allowing him any squares uh
Knight stage for going after magnus's
bishop and Magnus Retreats Bishop D6 we
have Pawn to F3 and it looks like Lucas
trapped magnus's Knight and E4 but the
problem is Google's Knight on H4 is also
trapped so Magnus just goes after it
pawn to G5 we have a trade of knights
here captures captures and now Bishop to
G5 putting pressure on the E7 pawn and
on the H4 Pawn so what does Magnus get
for messing up his Pawn structure and
for allowing maybe even a quick attack
against his King well uh uh you'll see
now he could decide he goes for Pawn to
F6 but the problem is if he goes for
something like H3 which is a move one
might consider you don't really have a
good reply but should be seven captures
Rook to E8 and now I have to Rook to C1
which is coming in all of the lines you
will grab that free Tempo against the
black queen queen D7 You're Gonna Play
Bishop D6 and okay you can capture but I
mean nothing is really happening there
the rule comes into the attack and the
gookish is perfectly fine
so Magnus Instead try spawn to F6 and
now Rook to C1 better to get the Rook
into the game before deciding on
anything else Queen to B7 and now Bishop
captures an H4 with d captures an E4 and
now Rook to C3 helping out with the
defense along the third rank but also
shifting that Rook into the attack and
while Magnus could decide for something
like f characters and E5 I mean it does
the win him the E5 Pawn uh then Rook C
to E3 and look at this this is a very
weird setup Here pawn bishop Bishop Pawn
uh that it's hard to imagine that this
will remain as it is so you're gonna
probably have to give up most of that
material so instead of Pawn to F5 by
Magnus and now uh Bishop uh goes to G5
of course he doesn't want to allow F4
but he's not in time to actually stop it
so upon the F4 it now comes Queen to C2
and this is the first uh not even the
mistake well maybe at this level it can
be even be character rise there's a
mistake may I would call it an
inaccuracy you have to play Rook to F1
here that's the problem but even this
looks very ugly for googash for example
Pawn to F3 you have to trade here
captures captures now Rook F captures uh
on F3 and okay The Rook is nicely
defended uh and the game continues with
black always being slightly better here
I mean it's completely open position
Magnus has the bishop pair uh but Booker
does have the strong Center so you know
a black is uh to be preferred a little
bit here the problem is he played Queen
to C2 Queen to C1 would make a bit more
sense but it's very hard to uh to
understand why Google played this
because he thought he had time for Rook
to C7 but Magnus says Nope you do not
have time for Rook to C7 but only if he
finds the correct move why he doesn't
have time for Rook to C7 and that moves
Pawn to H6 and this is sometimes it's
funny just when you know this this is
the threat and you you know a move like
H6 on the other sides of the side of the
board completely stops that plan it's
basically a butterfly effect in chest
point now is that I have to Rook the C7
uh you have Rook a to C8 a move which
would not be possible had wukish played
Queen to C1 because the queen and C1
would be defended the queen and C2 is
undefended and now a trade here is uh
well just favors Magnus for example
Bishop captures on E7 you play F3 you're
threatening Ponte F2 check and that will
be game over uh so here you have to
react to that you're gonna play
something like Rook F1 now even F2 with
checking H1 and Rook to F7 and white is
pretty much without a move that's a rook
B8 check you can prolong the game a
little bit Bishop to H4 but now E3 E2
and Lucas would resign so that's the
problem if he continues with his planned
maneuver so he moves the bishop back and
now Magnus goes Pawn to E3 now the
problem is uh well okay it seems like
you could play Rook the C7 now but Rook
8 the C8 still poses the same problems
the queen and C2 is undefended so uh you
know okay Rook def one would have been
better in that line but the queen and C1
would really be better than C2 and here
glucose tried Queen to G6 okay now
something is happening is also on the
attack uh the bishop here also hanging
Magnus just defends it and now we have
Rook uh e to C1 doubling up on the C
file uh Magnus plays Bishop capture some
B3 a captures and now Queen captures on
D4 saying there's no reason to fear
anything here uh Lucas plays Rook the C7
now uh it almost looks like he's coming
after magnus's King but Magnus calmly
defends a rook 88 with Bishop to E1 and
now Queen captures an E5 uh we have real
characters on A7 and Magnus quickly goes
for Queen to F5 he offers a queen trade
and really you should just accept this
queen trade and try to try to play the
same game for example real captures Rook
C2 maybe maybe you can survive but after
this queen to F5 Google play the Queen
captures on B6 grabbing yet more
material but now the game is completely
winning for Magnus and I'm sure you guys
can do do it without even pausing the
video it's the move you wanted to play
for the last 10 moves and then of course
is spawn to F3 uh Magnus played it and
now how do you defend F2 check is the
huge threat so Google's captured we have
Queen captures and now Queen to E6 check
August prolonging the game a little bit
but not uh you know not by much King to
H7 and now H3 giving out giving the H2
Square for the white king so you don't
just get checkmated in one but now it's
a force to Checkmate in eight and of
course you guys know uh where it is the
queen F1 I will get the job done Magnus
played this we have King to H2 and now
Queen to E2 with check where if the
white king goes back then Rook to F1 is
Checkmate so you have to go up the board
King to G3 we have Rook to F3 with check
now forcing some very nasty discoveries
or you go at the age for them Queen to
G2 and so on uh did go for H4 and now
Bishop to F6 with check and it was in
this position on move 36 that uh gookish
resigned in the game and very nice
victory for Magnus Carlsen in round of
this year's uh super super United rapid
tournament currently being played in
Zagreb Croatia the problem is now you
have to go it doesn't really matter if
you go to H5 and then a rook to F5 is a
discovery and the Checkmate immediately
and if you don't you're gonna get there
eventually for example King G4 runs into
H5 with check you have to go to H5 and
then again Rook the F5 a nice double
Discovery uh will uh result in checkmate
uh so yeah uh that's the game I really
hope you guys enjoyed it uh very nice
start for Magnus costs and in round one
of this year's uh uh super nice rapid
tournament in Croatia I hope you enjoyed
that like I said if you haven't seen my
previous video Ivano mochic versus uh
everyone in the grand Chester do check
it out it will be the first link in the
description below and the second link
the the merchandise you requested
unleash the Bish if you like it to do
check it out uh you know uh maybe there
is something for you there actually I'm
once again really hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank James Eugene Cashman
uh Josh Stanton not complies bullet just
thriller.com and uh Paul Miller for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing uh the coverage of
the super United rappling Bliss
tournament in Croatia until it finishes
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day